I'm Ken Block racecar driver of the
Hoonigan racing divisions I started
racing in 2005 and absolutely loved it
since then I've done a lot of Gymkhana
racing in videos
it's quite a surprise how the the
general public has really viewed those I
had no idea when we put it up on the
internet that it would get the views
that it caught
I don't want something that looks like
it would be in a movie
they have to fake so many things I
wanted to look as real as possible
because everything you see in those
videos I've done
it can be kind of nerve-wracking because
of the pressure to get it done so quick
and so well so that the production
schedule can stay on time the first
budget of the first one was only like 30
grand it was four guys over two days and
that was practically nothing you know
but I know that those videos are upwards
of a million dollars or something like
that to produce nowadays
I can't tell you how many times I've
been in you know signing autographs and
you got a dad with like a ten-year-old
son then they say we've watched so many
your videos on YouTube and we follow you
through your Instagram and Facebook and
that today is just such a change from 10
years ago we actually adjust kind of our
content delivery product delivery even
the liveries that go on the cars based
on the feedback of the kids that we
interact with for me to get in these
cars and drive them as fast as I can
it's just it's one of them funnest
things I've ever done in my life